Ahora mismo, un escenario que a todos nos
gustaría ver, es la caída de Putin.
Que su régimen colapse.
A fin de cuentas, esta es una de las razones
detrás del régimen de sanciones: poner a
las élites rusas en contra del gran líder.
Por eso, hablamos de un aislamiento que va
mucho más allá del comercio.
El objetivo es llegar al corazón de todos
los rusos.
Por ejemplo, hace 4 años, Rusia organizaba
el Mundial de Fútbol.
En el que se celebra en Qatar no les dejan
ni participar.
Sin embargo, el propio Putin también está
empezando a jugar demasiado con las emociones
de su pueblo.
Atentos.
(La llamada a filas de Putin alimenta la ira,
las protestas y la violencia de los rusos)
Para que os hagáis una idea, según FORBES,
más de 700.000 rusos abandonaron el país
en tan sólo las 2 semanas siguientes al anuncio
de la movilización.
Y diréis ¿Podemos fiarnos de estos números?
Pues lo cierto es que es relativamente fácil
hacer el recuento.
Basta con sumar las cifras que dan los países
de acogida.
Por supuesto, puede haber errores.
Pero, en principio, parece razonable pensar
que cientos de miles de rusos están escapando
de los reclutadores.
También hemos visto todo tipo de protestas
en la calle y de quejas por Internet.
Pensadlo bien: una cosa es apoyar una guerra
que ves por la TV, acompañada de la conveniente
propaganda… y otra muy distinta es apoyar
una guerra donde tu vas a combatir al frente.
Y lo cierto es que no es la primera vez que
esto pasa en Rusia ¡Habéis oído bien!
Si miramos un poco de historia, veremos que,
antes de Ucrania, Rusia ha hecho 2 grandes
movilizaciones: una en la II Guerra Mundial
y otra en la Primera.
Durante la II Guerra Mundial, casi todos los
rusos entendieron que tenían que luchar ¡A
fin de cuentas, estaban siendo invadidos por
Alemania!
Sin embargo, la movilización de la I Guerra
Mundial terminó realmente mal para el Kremlin.
En este caso, se desató todo un motín militar.
Un motín que fue clave para la caída de
los zares y el ascenso de los bolcheviques.
¡Habéis oído bien!
En el vídeo de hoy vamos a ver, con todo
detalle, qué sucedió en Rusia en 1917.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Qué tienen en común
la Rusia de los zares con la Rusia de Putin?
¿Podría la guerra de Ucrania provocar un
colapso del régimen como el que propició
las revoluciones de 1917?
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a responder a estas
preguntas.
Pero antes vamos a ver un poco de historia.
[Pero antes de empezar y hablando de imperios….
¿Habéis oído decir que China puede estar
a punto de sufrir una enorme crisis económica
y financiera?
Me apuesto a que casi todos habéis oído
hablar de la burbuja inmobiliaria y las ciudades
fantasmas en China.
Pues bien, ahora este problema amenaza con
causar toda una enorme crisis financiera.
Pero, ¿hasta qué punto la economía china
está en problemas?
¿Cómo piensa el gobierno de Xi Jinping darle
la vuelta a esta situación?
Para saber más sobre esta cuestión no te
pierdas el vídeo que le han dedicado a este
tema en Si lo Hubiera Sabido, el canal de
información financiera de Mutuactivos.
Os dejo el enlace en la descripción]
Dicho esto, ahora sí, volvamos a la era de
los zares.
T1(LA REVOLUCIÓN DE FEBRERO)
No, no os hemos equivocado.
Hemos dicho “La revolución de Febrero”
y no la “Revolución de Octubre”, que
es la que todos conocemos.
Y es que, meses antes de que los comunistas
se hicieran con el control de Rusia, se produjo
otra revolución.
Esta vez, una revolución liberal.
Y diréis ¿Por qué?
¡Vamos a verlo!
El Imperio Ruso atravesaba por una etapa de
profunda decadencia a principios del siglo
XX.
Las reformas para modernizar Rusia y acercarse
a otras potencias europeas habían quedado
truncadas con el asesinato del zar Alejandro
II.
Su sucesor Alejandro III volvió a la vieja
fórmula que emplearon los Romanov durante
3 siglos: una mezcla de ortodoxia, autocracia
y nacionalismo.
Es decir, la clásica ideología de la Rusia
zarista basada en la lealtad hacia el Gobierno
de la dinastía Romanov, la fe religiosa tradicional
y la glorificación de la madre patria.
Peor aún lo hizo Nicolas II: primero emprendió
una guerra con Japón que condujo a una de
las mayores humillaciones históricas de Rusia.
El descontento provocó la Revolución de
1905, en la que el zar hizo algunas concesiones
simbólicas como la creación de la Duma,
una asamblea parlamentaria que al fin y al
cabo carecía de poder real.
Pero es que, más tarde, en 1914 se erigió
en el defensor del nacionalismo serbio e involucró
a Rusia en la Gran Guerra, la Primera Guerra
Mundial.
Rusia se enfrentó en la guerra a Alemania
y al Imperio Austrohúngaro.
A pesar de las victorias iniciales ante los
austríacos, el Ejército ruso fue aplastado
por Alemania, causando miles de bajas.
El frente se estabilizó y el zar Nicolas
II partió al frente a dirigir a sus tropas.
A pesar del éxito de la ofensiva Brusilov,
cimentada sobre medio millón de bajas, pronto
Rusia se vio acorralada de nuevo para sufrir
derrota tras derrota.
1917 comenzó en Rusia con mucho frío y una
gran inflación.
La mayoría de obreros de San Petersburgo
tenía que elegir entre pasar frío o tratar
de calentarse a costa de pasar hambre ya que
un huevo costaba cuatro veces más que en
1914 y la mantequilla cinco veces más.
Además de la escasez de alimentos y de la
extrema pobreza, 1,7 millones de rusos habían
muerto en la guerra.
Otros 5 millones estaban heridos, 1,5 millones
habían sido hechos prisioneros y otros tantos
habían desertado del Ejército.
Las protestas eran continuas y cada vez más
multitudinarias.
Hasta que finalmente tuvo lugar la Revolución
de Febrero ¡Y no!
No estamos hablando de la revolución bolchevique!
Hablamos de la que tuvo lugar meses antes.
Esta no era una revolución comunista sino
una revolución liberal.
En este caso, el zar intentó sofocar la revuelta
por la fuerza pero las diferentes guarniciones
de San Petersburgo se sublevaron y desobedecieron
las órdenes recibidas.
Una semana después, Nicolas II abdicó.
El zarismo fue reemplazado por un Gobierno
provisional que decidió continuar con la
participación de Rusia en la Gran Guerra
respetando las alianzas internacionales en
las que el zar Nicolas II había involucrado
al país.
El problema de este Gobierno provisional es
que era muy débil.
En las calles cada vez se estaba volviendo
más poderoso el soviet de Petrogrado, una
especie de consejo de trabajadores y soldados
de la que entonces era la capital rusa, la
actual San Petersburgo.
Mientras los revolucionarios más radicales,
los bolcheviques, se hacían poco a poco más
fuertes en el Soviet de Petrogrado, el Gobierno
provisional ruso era integrado por políticos
liberales, socialistas moderados y un sociorrevolucionario
como Alexander Kerensky, que enseguida se
convirtió en ministro de Guerra y de Marina.
Al frente del ejército, Kerensky se la jugó
a un todo o nada.
¿En qué consistió este ataque a la desesperada
para evitar la derrota en la guerra?
Pues ahora mismo lo vemos.
T2( LA OFENSIVA KERENSKY)
Rusia se había comprometido con sus aliados
a lanzar una ofensiva para dividir la atención
del enemigo alemán y austrohúngaro en dos
frentes.
Pero el ejército ruso no atravesaba precisamente
por su mejor momento.
La disciplina había caído enormemente tras
la abdicación del zar.
La tropa desconfiaba de los mandos debido
a la enorme cantidad de bajas sufridas por
el Ejército ruso.
Tantas bajas tenían además dos consecuencias
fundamentales para Rusia.
Primero, que aunque los soldados seguían
siendo fundamentalmente de origen campesino,
los últimos reclutamientos de 1916 habían
comenzado a incluir a hombres de mediana edad.
Segundo, y más importante aún, que los nuevos
reclutas se enviaban al frente con una instrucción
menor a las de sus predecesores.
Vamos, que eran carne de cañón ¿Os suena
esta historia?
¡Exacto!
No vamos a decir que la historia se está
repitiendo.
Pero está claro que hay unos cuentos paralelismos.
(Las nuevas tropas de Putin sufrirán mucho
en Ucrania ya que básicamente no tendrán
entrenamiento, según la inteligencia del
Reino Unido.)
En 1917 esta falta de preparación también
afectaba a los oficiales, especialmente en
los grados bajos del escalafón.
De todo esto eran conscientes los altos oficiales,
que se quejaban de la escasa capacidad de
los nuevos mandos y de la poca calidad de
los refuerzos recibidos.
Pero esperad un momento, porque aún tenían
que lidiar con un problema aún mayor:
Los recién llegados al frente se oponían
a la guerra y pensaban que el fracaso de la
ofensiva Kerensky hundiría al Gobierno provisional
y serviría para alcanzar más rápidamente
la paz.
Algo parecido a lo que pueden estar pensando
ahora mismo muchos rusos en Ucrania.
La propaganda rusa ha vendido la invasión
de Ucrania como una operación del Ejército
para luchar contra el fascismo en EL país
vecino.
Los rusos ven por tanto la intervención en
Ucrania como algo completamente ajeno al día
a día de su propio país.
A principios del siglo XX, los rusos tampoco
consideraban la Primera Guerra Mundial como
una cuestión existencial.
Es algo que tienen en común la Rusia de los
zares y la Rusia de Putin: la falta de una
ideología clara a la hora de dirigir el país.
Está claro que los ucranianos luchan para
sobrevivir como país.
Quieren ser independientes y tener un sistema
político democrático parecido al de la Unión
Europea.
Pero ¿por qué luchan los rusos?
A diferencia de la era soviética, actualmente
el Kremlin carece de una ideología tan clara
como el comunismo.
Dicho de otra forma: los soviéticos querían
extender su revolución por todos los rincones
del planeta.
Sin embargo, el Putinismo no tiene esas aspiraciones
internacionales ¡Nada más lejos de la realidad!
El planteamiento de Putin es puramente nacionalista;
se basa en la idea de que no hay nada mejor
en la vida que ser ruso; esa vieja noción
romántica del nacionalismo que ya explotaban
los zares.
Sin embargo amigos, en pleno siglo XXI esto
no es motivación suficiente para ir al frente.
Y menos en las condiciones en las que el Kremlin
envía a sus hombres.
(La indignación aumenta a medida que los
reclutas rusos son lanzados a la batalla sin
entrenamiento ni equipo)
La ofensiva Kerensky fracasó cuando los soldados
rusos se amotinaron y rechazaron seguir combatiendo.
Estas insubordinaciones dieron tiempo a Alemania
para reforzar el frente y lanzar una contraofensiva.
​ Lejos de reforzar la moral del Ejército
ruso, la ofensiva probó que la moral de sus
tropas estaba por los suelos y que ninguno
de sus generales podía contar con que los
soldados bajo su mando ejecutasen las órdenes
que les diesen.
Los problemas se acumulaban para el Gobierno
provisional ruso, que para entonces llevaba
varios meses sujeto por alfileres gracias
a la brillante idea que había tenido el enemigo
alemán.
Porque alguien pensó: a ver, si Lenin quiere
negociar la paz con nosotros ¿por qué no
le sacamos de su exilio en Suiza y le metemos
en Rusia?
Y como decimos en VisualPolitik…
dicho y hecho.
En abril de 1917 se produjo un viaje en tren
crucial para la Historia.
Vladimir Lenin viajó de Zurich a San Petersburgo.
Recorrió más de 3.000 kilómetros, algo
imposible en plena Guerra Mundial sin la ayuda
alemana.
Pero las ambiciones de Berlín rápidamente
se vieron recompensadas.
A su llegada a San Petersburgo, Lenin anunció
las Tesis de Abril.
Prometió que si los bolcheviques llegaban
al Gobierno, Rusia saldría de la guerra,
darían la tierra a los campesinos y el poder
al proletariado.
Fue el momento del histórico lema de ¡Todo
el poder para los soviets!
Es lo que tiene recurrir a un agitador de
las masas como Lenin.
Que sabía perfectamente qué querían escuchar
los rusos.
Hoy día la oposición a Putin no presenta
un líder, una figura de referencia que aglutine
el descontento de los rusos con la guerra.
Y no parece que nadie esté apoyando a la
oposición rusa.
Al menos no con la misma intensidad y sobre
todo, con tantos rublos como los que la Alemania
del Kaiser colocó en manos de los bolcheviques
hace un siglo.
Eduard Bernstein, un político alemán que
está considerado como uno de los padres de
la socialdemocracia, aseguraba que el Gobierno
alemán financió a los bolcheviques entre
1917 y 1918 con cerca de 10 millones de dólares
de la época para ayudarlos a tomar el poder.
Hoy día el apoyo occidental se está concentrando
en sostener al Gobierno de Ucrania.
Pero apoyar a la oposición rusa fue muy efectivo
hace un siglo.
¿Cómo se hicieron los bolcheviques con el
poder?
Atentos.
T3(LA REVOLUCIÓN DE OCTUBRE)
Después del fracaso de la ofensiva, el Gobierno
provisional dirigido por Kerensky intentó
reorganizar el ejército colocando a Lavr
Kornilov al frente.
Este general, harto del caos en el que estaba
sumido Rusia, intentó implantar una dictadura
militar.
Para ello lanzó un golpe de Estado contrarrevolucionario.
Kornilov fracasó pero no por la oposición
del Gobierno provisional de Kerensky, que
a estas alturas realmente ya no tenía poder
sobre nadie pues nadie creía en su autoridad.
Kornilov se topó con los soviets y fundamentalmente
con la resistencia de los bolcheviques.
Este golpe fallido reforzó la pérdida de
autoridad de los oficiales ante las tropas,
que les veían como simples representantes
de un poder autoritario con el que había
que acabar.
También supuso el espaldarazo definitivo
de los bolcheviques, los revolucionarios más
radicales que garantizaban que no habría
vuelta atrás al zarismo.
Los bolcheviques exigieron al Gobierno libertad
de movimientos para la guardia roja.
Hablamos de destacamentos de obreros que estaban
armados y que serían decisivos para el éxito
de la Revolución.
Los bolcheviques aunaron a los trabajadores
y soldados de Petrogrado para derrocar al
gobierno provision al.
Se formó un nuevo Ejecutivo, dirigido por
Lenin, que tomó el control del campo y creó
la Checa, una organización de inteligencia
política y militar dirigida a aplastar cualquier
tipo de disidencia.
Además, tal y cómo habían prometido, firmaron
la paz con Alemania, un acuerdo que supuso
una independencia efímera para la República
de Ucrania.
El triunfo de la Revolución de Octubre dio
comienzo a una guerra civil de 6 años.
Se enfrentaron el Ejército Rojo y el Blanco,
que agrupaba a todos los enemigos de la revolución
bolchevique.
El conflicto devastó por completo al país
y culminó con el triunfo del poder soviético.
Posiblemente hoy día no se dan las condiciones
para una revolución que derroque a Putin.
Dicho de otra forma ¿Quién es ahora el principal
líder de la oposición antiPutin?
Alexei Navalny.
A diferencia de Lenin, en su día, Navalny
no está en el exilio sino en una cárcel
rusa.
Vamos, que parece un tanto difícil poderle
apoyar desde Occidente.
Aún así, los aliados de Navalny continúan
moviéndose.
Este mensaje lanzó a principios de octubre
Ivan Zhdanov, mano derecha de Navalny y que
se encuentra actualmente en
el exilio.
El problema para las revoluciones es que las
cosas han cambiado mucho desde los tiempos
de Lenin.
El control sobre la sociedad, sobre las comunicaciones
de los disidentes, es mucho mayor que el que
se podía tener hace un siglo.
Y otra de las ventajas de Putin es que no
está tan desgastado ante la población rusa.
Fundamentalmente porque la propaganda del
régimen no trata de convencer a los rusos
de que el mundo necesita a Putin al igual
que por ejemplo el chavismo ensalzaba la figura
de Hugo Chávez.
Es muy diferente.
La popularidad de Putin siempre ha descansado
en la apatía de la gente, algo similar a
lo vivido durante la época zarista.
Hace tiempo que los rusos entienden que la
política es cosa de Putin y de sus amigos.
Ahora bien, cómo la guerra de Ucrania está
lejos de ir cómo esperaba el Kremlin, el
descontento está produciendo movimientos
que hace meses eran totalmente inesperados.
¿Cuáles?
Ahora mismos los vamos a ver.
T4(LA OFENSIVA PUTIN)
El Kremlin ha doblado su apuesta con la movilización
parcial y, como os podéis imaginar, esto
no sale gratis.
Como todo el mundo entiende, salvó el checheno
Kadyrov, eso de ir al frente en general no
hace gracia.
Y menos sin la preparación adecuada.
Además, para cuando se anunció el llamamiento
a filas, ya habían transcurrido 7 meses de
guerra.
Más de medio año en el que muchos han visto
cómo sus compatriotas regresaban heridos
o incluso en un féretro.
Así que algunos se han atrevido a levantar
la voz contra cómo se está llevando a cabo
la movilización.
Es el caso del presidente de la República
de Daguestán.
La República de Daguestán es una región
rusa que hace frontera con Georgia y Azerbaiyán,
a orillas del Caspio.
Pues bien, el gobernador de esta región es
este señor que veis en pantalla: Sergey Melikov.
Sergey Melikov no es ningún enemigo de Putin
ni muchísimo menos.
Tiene una carrera militar de altos vuelos:
ha llegado a ser un alto rango en la Guardia
Nacional.
Ahora es la máxima autoridad en esta región
de Rusia.
Sin embargo, mirad lo que ha dicho sobre los
oficiales de reclutamiento de las fuerzas
armadas.
Pensadlo así: Dagestán en una de las regiones
más pobres de Rusia.
Además, tiene una población de poco más
de 3 millones de habitantes.
Melikov tiene miedo de que muchos de esos
miles de jóvenes no vuelvan y dejen a su
república aún más envejecida.
Pero esperad un momento, porque el descontento
con cómo se ha organizado la movilización
parcial de Rusia va mucho más allá de un
problema anecdótico del Daguestán.
Es una tendencia constatada: las regiones
más pobres y marginadas de Rusia son las
que más están arriesgando en Ucrania.
(Las minorías étnicas de Rusia lamentan
la guerra en Ucrania)
Hay grandes incógnitas sobre las bajas rusas
porque ya sabéis que en las guerras la transparencia
es la primera víctima.
Pero hay investigaciones que s eñalan claramente
que los soldados procedentes de las regiones
más pobres de la Federación, como Buriatia
en la frontera con Mongolia o el propio Daguestán,
están representados de manera desproporcionadamente
alta entre las bajas rusas.
De igual modo, apenas están muriendo en la
guerra los jóvenes procedentes de las grandes
capitales del país.
Sin duda un movimiento inteligente por parte
de Putin, porque mantener la lealtad de las
élites le mantendrá en el poder.
Las revoluciones del siglo XX se extendían
de las ciudades a la periferia y nunca al
revés.
Esta vez no habrá soviets de Petrogrado pero
ojo con irritar a las repúblicas periféricas.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Creéis que en algún
momento puede caer el régimen de Putin?
¿O pensáis que su control sobre la sociedad
rusa es tan grande que una revolución es
completamente imposible?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y, por supuesto, no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas.
Así que suscribíos al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
¡Un abrazo y hasta pronto!